l'album saveurs personne puisque
impressionne manitoba personne et ça va
très très vite
alors les gens qui ont les cheveux
d'argent ne comprennent pas pourquoi
savoir si c'est vite alors j'ai eu
l'idée de caen une chanson qui s'appelle
personne et ça fonctionne bien comme
c'était le comprend comment es tu venu à
la musique je suis mis en musique de mai
dès l'enfance je commence à chanter mes
grands-parents m'ont mis à l'espérance
j'ai suivi et puis quand je suis arrivé
en métropole je suis allé au
conservatoire de marseille et en et en
gagnant concours de chant à sur au monte
carlo dans une émission qui s'appelle
une émission chapeau
j'ai réussi puis deux puis je suis parti
l'italie et l'espagne s'était appuyé bon
mais j'en ai posé ce métier
un professionnel comme ça et c'est une
fierté pour moi de pouvoir s'ils
n'avaient comme très peu entre
parenthèses très petit peu de moyens à
arriver à porter un peu de notre culture
dans des régions différentes
comment c'est perçu par exemple en
espagne au portugal et en italie
ils sont très proches de nous les
espagnols par rapport à par rapport aux
nôtres nous rythme begin le portugais
aussi par rapport aux au club parce
qu'ils ont un très très bon chanteur de
zouk love est par contre à l'italie oui
c'est vrai que c'est un tout petit peu
différent parce que le rythme ces
différents lots perception du sens c'est
un petit peu différent mais enfin c'est
ce qui fait notre rejet originalité et
chaque année tue son
non toujours dans les deux ans parce
qu'il faut quand même une bonne année
pour que cette musique prenne et que les
gens s'apprécient et puis après une
deuxième année on essaie de faire en
sorte pour notre album pour être dans le
vif de l'actualité